[ __ ] don't wanna answer the question
you shot the pants is the low bother
you've said I'm gonna get every [ __ ]
question
I would strap any for any stop
hello my name's Nick helm I'm gonna show
you with Nathan
and you're watching shocking shocking
answers
[Music]
what is something you hate also the
question you shot that question I didn't
want to okay what was the funniest
heckle you ever received none of them
are funny why is the delay on this piece
is the most embarrassing thing you have
ever done besides that's the rules of
the game why God okay why are you seeing
like a [ __ ] action bigger what is the
least acceptable belief that you hold oh
god that is actually quite a difficult
question so many outdated beliefs that I
have really can't get away with hey why
the administration of this game is
[ __ ] unacceptable by the way why is
that
[Music]
by buzzy Sullivan are you [ __ ] keep
watching this it should have been made
that cut shots
sorry just so you know this only happens
on the live bible shocking answers we
have two sex slaves are behind the curve
but unfortunately the two people at this
stage we're just getting shocked when
these two pricks feel like it because
they cannot see what's happening in the
game so the buzzes up on the table and
they're lying on the floor and whenever
one of us pushes the buzzer one of the
guys that I don't see the buzzer has to
shock us and then we're gonna subtract
these two [ __ ] up just get it cleared
the buzzer sounds Romesh this game is
you know you really are a piece of [ __ ]
but you're not finding this at all do
you stand up course it down when you
wipe your bum that is a great question I
sort of go sort of in-between because I
like to stand up because I like to look
back at what's been created also to
double-check you have done a [ __ ] I
might have [ __ ] myself since we started
this now that I've actually started this
genuinely I've Chinese gonna go about
the wet wipes yes environmentally
friendly wet wipes
[Laughter]